let me step back what is consciousness
eleazaridkowski what is consciousness
I'm referring to chalmers's hard problem
of conscious experience are you
referring it to self-awareness and
reflection are referring to the state of
being awake as opposed to asleep
this is how I know you're an advanced
language model I did give you a simple
prompt and you gave me a bunch of
options uh
I think I'm referring to all
with
including the hard problem of
Consciousness what is it in its
importance
to what you've just been talking about
which is intelligence
is it a foundation to intelligence is it
intricately connected to intelligence in
the human mind or is it is it a side
effect of the human mind it is
a useful little tool like we can get rid
of I guess I'm trying to get
some color in your opinion
of how useful it is in the intelligence
of a human being and then try to
generalize that to AI whether AI will
keep some of that
so I think that for there to be like a
person who I care about looking out at
the universe and wondering at it and
appreciating it
it's not enough to have a model of
yourself
I think that it is useful to an
intelligent mind to have a model of
itself but
I think you can have that without
pleasure
pain
Aesthetics
emotion
a sense of wonder
um
like I think you can have a model of
like how much memory you're using and
whether
like
this thought or that thought is is like
more likely to lead to a winning
position and
you can have like the use I think that
if you optimize really hard on
efficiently just having the useful parts
there is not then the think that the
thing that says like I am here I look
out I wonder
I feel happy in this I feel sad about
that
I think there's a thing that knows what
it is thinking but that doesn't quite
care
about these are my thoughts this is my
me and that matters
does that make you sad if that's lost in
egi I think that if that's lost then
every then basically everything that
matters is lost
I think that when you optimize that when
you go really hard on making tiny
molecular spirals or paper clips
that when you like grind much harder
than on that then natural selection
round out to make humans
that
there isn't then the mess
and intricate loopiness
and
like complicated pleasure pain
conflicting preferences this type of
feeling that kind of feeling there's a
you know in humans there's like this
difference between like the desire of
wanting something and the pleasure of
having it and it's all these like
evolutionary clutches that came together
and created something that then looks of
itself and says like this is pretty this
matters
and the thing that I worry about is that
this is not the the thing that happens
again just the way that it happens in us
or even like quite similar enough that
there's that there are like many basins
of attractions here and we are in the
space of an attra of Attraction like
looking out and saying like ah what a
lovely Basin we are in and there are
other basins of Attraction and we do not
end up in and the AIS do not end up in
this one when they go like way harder on
optimizing themselves the natural
selection optimized us
Because unless you specifically want to
end up in the state where you're looking
out saying I am here I look out at this
universe with wonder if you don't want
to preserve that it doesn't get
preserved when you grind really hard and
be able to get more of the stuff
we would choose to preserve that within
ourselves because it matters and on some
viewpoints is the only thing that
matters
and that in part is uh preserving that
is in part
a solution to the human alignment
problem
I don't I think the human alignment
problem is a terrible phrase because it
is very very different to like try to
build systems out of humans some of whom
are nice and some of whom are not nice
and some of whom are trying to trick you
and like build a social system out of
like large populations of those who are
like all basically the same level of
intelligence yes you know like IQ this
IQ that but like that versus chimpanzees
like it is very different to try to
solve that problem than to try to build
an AI from scratch using especially if
God help you are trying to use gradient
descent on giant inscrutable matrices
they're just very different problems and
I think that all the analogies between
them are horribly misleading and I yeah
even though so you don't think through
where for reinforcement learning the
human feedback something like that but
much much more elaborate as possible to
to understand this full
complexity of human nature and then code
it into the machine
I don't think you are trying to do that
on your first try I think on your first
try you are like trying to build an
you know okay like
probably not what you should actually do
but like let's say you were trying to
build something that is like Alpha fold
17 and you are trying to get it to solve
the biology problems associated with
making humans smarter so that demons can
like actually solve alignment
so you've got like a super biologist and
you would like it to and I think what
you want in the situation is for to like
just be thinking about biology and not
thinking about a very wide range of
things that includes how to kill
everybody
and I think that that you're that the
first AIS you're trying to build not a
million years later the first ones
look more like narrowly specialized
biologists than like
getting the full complexity and wonder
of human experience in there in such a
way that it wants to preserve itself
even as it becomes much smarter which is
a drastic system change is going to have
all kinds of side effects that you know
like if we're dealing with giant
scootable matrices we're not very likely
to be able to see coming in advance so
but I don't think it's just the matrices
is we're also dealing with the data
right with the with the uh with the data
on the on the internet and then this is
an interesting discussion about the data
set itself but the data set includes the
full complexity of human nature no it's
a it's a it's a shadow cast by yes by
humans on the internet but don't you
think that shadow
uh is a youngin Shadow I think that if
you had
alien super intelligence is looking at
the data they would be able to pick up
from it an excellent picture of what
humans are actually like inside this
does not mean that if you have a loss
function of predicting the next token
from that data set that the Mind picked
out by gradient descent to be able to
predict the next token as well as
possible on a very wide variety of
humans is itself a human
but don't you think it is
has humanness a deep
humanness to it in the tokens it
generates when those tokens are read and
interpreted by humans
I think that if you sent me to a distant
Galaxy with aliens who are like much
much stupider than I am
so much so that I could do a pretty good
job of predicting what they'd say even
though they thought in an utterly
different way from how I did
that I might in time be able to learn
how to
imitate those aliens if the intelligence
Gap was great enough that my own
intelligence could overcome the
alienness
and the aliens would look at my outputs
and say like is there not a deep
like name of alien nature to this thing
and what they would be seeing was that I
had correctly understood them but not
that I was similar to them